il y a deux chemins le bon chemin c'est
à gauche tout se passe bien si tu vas à
droite toi tu meurs soit tu te noie donc
il va pas il y a des cours en rapides et
tout si tu vas à droite tu reviens ta
respiration et ta forme ok c'est vrai
allez huit neuf 12 on y va
la brillance c'est quoi ça c'est éclaté
les amis merci
mon quinzième il est là vous êtes allé
me le chercher au bout de l'année avec
vos votes donc voilà merci du fond du
cœur de toujours présent de toujours
aussi mobiliser 20 ans après c'est
magnifique on se retrouve sur la tournée
on est ensemble ça bouge pas la faire
Daniela
[Musique]
OK
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce mais
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce binz là
[Musique]
mais on est mais on est des dingues on
est des fous là
ça y est les puces je suis dans le métro
et alors là je descends les escaliers je
tombe direct sur ces affiches que vous
pouvez retrouver dans dans plein plein
de stations j'ai vraiment voulu pour
cette semaine de lutte contre le
harcèlement mettre un QR code qui
renvoie vers ma plateforme de lutte
contre le harcèlement si tu es victime
de harcèlement viens en parler sur ma
plateforme anonymement